elle tisse son fils avant de répéter ce
geste qu'elle maîtrise à la perfection
donc là je travaille sur une oeuvre qui
s'appelle le takara but n'est en fait
c'est une oeuvre qui me permet de
travailler les techniques d'or et
d'approfondir être perfectionné mais
techniques de broderie d'or en broderie
japonaise son premier point de croix
nadège antoine le pose à l'âge de 15 ans
habile elle apprend vite et sur le tas
notamment aux côtés des plus grands dior
lacroix ungaro ou encore armani c'est un
milieu qui est extraordinaire
ça c'est indéniable je peux pas
continuer à dire le contraire par
rapport à tout ce qu'on y fait des
techniques les matériaux qu'on utilise
mais c'est un métier aussi qui demande
énormément énormément de temps et qui
vous mange énormément termes de stress
de fatigue épuisé
cette maman de deux enfants s'engagent
alors comme factrice avant de lancer son
entreprise de broderies en 2015 ses
inspirations
nadège antoine les tirs du japon et de
l'univers des geishas comme avec cette
oeuvre baptisée les seasonal poème ce
225 heures de travail qui lui ont permis
de décrocher cette année le prix
départemental des métiers d'art donc là
on à l'automne nous avons le printemps
qui sont de saison majoritairement
finition importante dans la culture
japonaise on à l'été qui se présentent
dans le petit angle l'hiver est là c'est
pas une vraie saison mais c'est quelque
chose qui fait partie aussi de la la
culture japonaise qu'on appelle le
cosmos dont qui est une représentation
de l'éternité
fasciné par la broderie et le pays du
soleil levant leur ailier dessus depuis
deux ans une formation qui doit lui
permettre d'être approuvé par les
maîtres japonais
elle espère ainsi pouvoir enseigner cet
art et vivre de sa passion
et on est très peu nombreuses parce que
nous sommes que des filles nous sommes
très peu nombreuses en france
effectivement à enseigner avec
l'approbation des maîtres japonais
donc c'est dommage je dirais de ne pas
développer cette cet art auprès du plus
grand public
en attendant nadège antoine s'attèle
déjà un nouveau projet axé autour du
cinéma et les femmes des années 50